president Trump's new attorney Rudy
Giuliani is raising all kinds of
questions after his latest media blitz
the former mayor now saying the
president may not comply with a special
council subpoena we don't have to he's
the president United States we can
assert the same privilege as other
presidents have President Clinton
negotiated a deal in which he didn't
admit the effectiveness of the subpoena
testified and Mayor Giuliani is unsure
if the president will plead the fifth
are you confident the president will not
take the fifth in this case oh how could
I have a be confident of that when I'm
when I'm facing a situation with the
president and all the other lawyers are
in which every lawyer in America thinks
he'd be a fool to testify I've got a
client who wants to testify mr. Trump's
attorney not ruling out if Michael Cohen
made payments to other women on behalf
of the president think if it was
necessary yes he made payments for the
president or he he conducted business
for the president which means he had
legal fees monies laid out and
expenditures which I have on my bills to
my to my clients Wow so is Rudy Giuliani
helping or hurting his client the
president I'm gonna ask you to start us
off right um a couple of things I think
that the tone that he's setting is is
exactly the president was he's
aggressive enough of sitting on my hands
oh you want a million piece of paper you
can have it you want anything else I
hope you don't call me for a meeting
oh you're interviewing my friends you
are you're hassling my family it's okay
those days are over with Rudy Giuliani
has to do is inform people about what
he's doing he's got to understand it's a
legal team and even if he has the best
or worst plan
nobody everyone needs to know the
communications department didn't know
what he was doing and the rest of legal
team didn't know he was doing and it's
totally dispirited the White House in
particular I think President Trump and
Rudy Giuliani knew what they were doing
I don't think he was that surprised I
talked to him for a half hour on radio
half hour on Fox and Friends about 20
minutes on the phone that day before
there was no panic there was no oops
there was no what have I done here he
felt as though he was on path what he
has to do now is come back
say we got it we had to speak with one
voice you know in one way I think he set
the tone which is a positive and another
way he set him back on the stormy Daniel
situation so Dana I think a lot of
people were struck by some of the things
that Brian just said which is that folks
at the White House were like we didn't
know this was coming we didn't know this
was going on there all kinds of in shock
at this and in addition to which the
suggestion that there may be more
payments came is an absolute unsettling
factor I don't know I mean it there is a
school of thought amongst some people
that it's better for the press secretary
or the people doing Communications for
them not to know certain things because
it protects them from something I've
never subscribed to that theory but I
know that it exists and it'll turn out
however it turns out I the only thing
I'm focused on is something that I asked
John you who's the legal scholar he's at
Berkeley a very accomplished lawyer and
he knows a lot about the executive the
the branches of government and how they
have to interact and I said what is the
settled law of whether a president can
ignore a subpoena from the judicial
branch and he said that that it's like
one of the one things that has never
been decided by a Supreme Court so that
actually this could be kind of
interesting you're right it could be the
time the first time that is actually
decided yeah I think the court said that
you have to give them the dock and so
the question is about the testimony and
by the way Kimberly yes you hear the
president say you know Rudy's new to
this you'll get his facts straight and
which is like well does he is Rudy on
the page or not on the page Rudy's on
the page that's actually a vote of
confidence old residents say yes they're
very close he relies on his counsel and
he's saying look we've come on to the
case very quickly here he's catching up
getting up to speed on everything so now
he's going through it he's goal is to
bring him to protect the president
protect the family he's trying to be
forthright and transparent and answer
the questions he's not ruling anything
out or in and that's how it should be a
smart lawyer doesn't like you know
closed doors you have to make sure and
say okay this is what we're looking at
we're going to evaluate it make
case-by-case determination and and basis
here and in terms of whether or not the
president would have to you know testify
or would you take the fifth etc there's
some other legal hurdles and challenges
here and you've had some key rulings as
of late that have actually benefited the
president where you've seen the federal
just kind of put a stop to some of the
nonsense saying this is too wide in
scope we want to see the memo the scope
memo to make sure you can't just engage
in a fishing expedition and try to reel
in the president United States his
family members and anyone else that he
might you know have communicated or have
knowledge of this so I think that
there's gonna be some legal hurdles for
Malheur not to mention how many people
that he might have coming forward with
the testimony they're gonna be impeach
or have no credibility whatsoever like
you know in terms of the Muller
investigation so I think that's gonna be
important to who's gonna be left to
testify that hasn't been inconsistent
statements or resigned from the FBI or
written a book good luck so Greg the two
people left out of this one is
apparently jared is disposable and then
but Ivanka is off-limits don't go after
Ivanka and then Michael Cohen he says
yesterday Michael Cohen may be
cooperating with Muller yeah I I watched
the a lot of the coverage when I'm at
the gym not by choice and what I've
realized about this story and why I hate
it so much and I know most of America
hates it it is now lawyers interviewing
lawyers about what a lawyer said and
what are the legal ramifications of what
they said we're not sure so well let's
get a panel in to talk about it this
this is this story is bordering on the
tulip craze it's self fueled hysteria
generated by those in the media who feed
off an inside their bubble and they
don't care that outside the bubble
America really doesn't give a damn we
don't care this is how it starts they
wake up in the morning that the the the
TV executives should we do stormy or
should we do Muller
let's do stormy okay somebody said
something about stormy okay let's get a
panel in to talk about stormy all right
now let's get the legal panel to parse
the word to the person who just talked
about stormy
then we'll get the next panel in to pull
it for the political ramifications and
while this is all doing going on someone
else will then start the process over
again by saying something about Muller
so then you could switch from stormy to
Muller meanwhile Trump's numbers
continue to go up America gets
incredibly fed up and burned out by this
and I'm telling you there's gonna be if
there's gonna be a rebound to this that
is going to help Trump because people
are tired of hearing about lawyers and
experts talk about subpoena
and explaining and summarizing facts
that we really don't give a flying crap
about well you tell you what those two
judges who made those comments who I
thoroughly understood without a legal
degree who came out and said you don't
want Paul Mann afford you want Trump for
the other one says you had an indictment
and why don't you just produce the
evidence for this indictment I'm not
giving you any more time the IG reports
gonna be very revealing all right I
still don't care all right guys